You know,
in,
in sleeping beauty,
you know,
sleeping beauty goes to sleep and the
reason she goes to sleep is because you
have to remember what happens is she has
parents who were quite old and so
they're pretty desperate to have a child
like so many people are now and they
only have one child like so many people
do now and they don't want anything to
happen to this child because like,
hey,
it's a miracle and there's only one of
them,
and so she's the princess and so it's
like we're not letting anything around
her.
So they have a big christening party,
right.
And they invite everybody but they don't
invite maleficent and Melissa sent is
the terrible mother.
She's nature.
She's like the thing that goes bump in
the night.
She's the devil herself,
so to speak.
She's everything that you don't want
your child to encounter.
So the king and queen saying,
well,
we just want to invite her to the
Christening.
It's like,
well,
good luck with that.
That's an eatable story,
right?
The eatable mother is the mother who
devours her child by refusing,
by overprotecting him or her.
So that instead of being strengthened by
an encounter with the terrible world,
they're weakened by too much protection.
And then when they're lead out into the
world,
they cannot live,
and that's the story of sleeping beauty
and that's what the king and Queen do.
And they apologize to the,
to Melissa sent when she first shows up
and say,
well,
you know,
they have a bunch of halfway did excuses
why they don't invite her.
We forgot.
It's like,
I don't think so.
You know,
you don't forget something like that.
And she kind of makes that point.
It's right.
The whole horror of life.
You don't forget about that when you
have a child that's for sure.
You might wish that it would stay at
bay,
but you do not forget about it.
The question is,
do you invite it to the party?
And the answer is it bloody well.
Depends how unconscious you want your
child to be.
And if you want your child to be
unconscious,
well then you have the added advantage
that maybe they won't leave home.
And so you can take advantage of them
for the rest of your sad life.
Instead of going off to find something
to do for yourself,
well,
and then of course you can take revenge
on them if they do have eddie,
Eddie,
what would you call impetus towards
courage that you sacrificed yourself 30
years ago and want to stamp out as soon
as you see it develop in your child.
That's another thing that would be quite
pleasant,
and so that's what happens in sleeping
beauty.
Yeah,
well,
none of this is pleasant and nothing
that happens in that story is pleasant.
So sleeping beauty,
she's naive as hell.
They put her out in the forest and have
a raised by these three like goody two
shoes,
ferries that are also completely devoid
of any real potency and power,
right?
There's no nothing maleficent about
them.
And then the first idiot prints that
wanders by,
she falls in love with so badly that she
has post traumatic stress disorder
really writes off on his horse,
right?
That's what happens.
And then she,
then she goes into the castle and she's
all freaked out because she met the love
of her life for like five minutes for
God's sake.
And you know,
that's when the spinning wheel,
that's the wheel of fate pops up and she
picks her finger right?
They tried to get rid of all the
spinning wheels,
they tried to get rid of all the wheels
of fate with their pointed end,
but she finds it poke her fingers and
finger falls down unconscious while she
wants to be unconscious.
And no bloody wonder.
She was protected whole life.
She so damn naive that her first love
affair just about kills her.
She wants to go to sleep and never wake
up.
And so that's exactly what happens.
And then she has to wait for the prince
to come and rescue her.
While you think,
how sexist can you get that story?
Well,
seriously,
because that's,
that's the way that that would be red.
And in the modern world it's like she
doesn't need a prince to rescue her.
That's why Disney made frozen that
absolutely appalling piece of rubbish.
So you know,
you can say,
well the princess doesn't need a prince
to rescue her,
but you know,
that's a boneheaded way of looking at
the story because the prince isn't just
a man who's coming to rescue the woman
and believe me,
he's got his own problems,
right?
He's gonna,
hold God damn dragon he has to contend
with.
But.
But the prince also represents the
woman's own consciousness.
That consciousness is presented very
frequently and stories as symbolically
masculine as it is with the logos idea.
And the idea is that without,
without that forward going,
courageous consciousness,
a woman herself will drift into
unconsciousness and terror and so you
can read it as well.
The woman who's sleeping needs a man to
wake her up and of course just like a
man needs a woman to wake him up.
It's the same damn thing that's the
dragon fight in sleeping beauty.
But it's also the case that if she's
only unconscious,
all she can do is lay there and sleep
the sleep of the naive and damned.
She has to wake up,
wake herself up,
and bring her own consciousness around
masculine consciousness into the
forefront so that she can survive in the
world.
And of course women are trying to do
that like mad,
but that's partly what's represented in
the store like that.
And that's partly what's implicit in
this idea is that unless the woman is
taken out of man,
so to speak,
then she isn't a human being.
She's just a creature.
And that's partly what's embedded in
this story.
So you don't want to read it as a
patriarchal.
You don't want to read anything that
way.
So really it's really.
It's.
Yeah,
I won't,
I won't bother with that,
but really we can do better than that.
Man.